packet and give you a run through on
exactly how to correctly go through and
mark your ballot and send it back in to
be processed
and counted for the november third
election first off
the mailers that you'll be receiving at
the end of september
include your sample ballot
which has information on your early
voting and election day locations
your actual ballot that you will be
eligible to vote for all contests and
candidates
and other information related to voting
in general
the second mailer that you'll be
receiving at about the same time is the
mail ballot
supplement and this supplement includes
instructions on mail-in voting and also
all of the language for the questions
that you'll be voting for in the
selection
important to note that there are five
questions on your ballot that you'll be
marking
however they run one through four
question
five is cancelled and then it goes to
question six
that is very clearly notated in your
sample ballot and on the ballot that you
will actually be voting
and then more importantly you're going
to be receiving a mail-in packet
all active registered voters in clark
county will be receiving this
this is exactly what that document
looks like that you'll be receiving in
the mail
you'll notice that this particular
mailer is identifying a voter who is id
required not all voters in nevada are
required to show
id at the polling place so be sure
that if it is marked id required on the
mailer that you receive that you're
providing us a copy of your nevada
driver's license or id
along with any of the alternate ids that
are clearly indicated in the
instructions we provide
[Applause]
inside of each of your mail-in packets
you will receive a return
envelope very important for all voters
to understand
do not sign your actual ballot
you will be signing on the back of your
return envelope
at this x clearly putting your signature
here so that we have it to identify your
signature and verify your identity
this mailer is postage paid
so if you choose to drop this in a
mailbox it'll make it safely to the
election apartment
we have no reason to believe that the
u.s post office will have any trouble
getting these back to us
however if you would prefer to drop this
off in person
we are also providing you with a mail
ballot
drop-off listing very easy for all
voters to remember
without even looking at this schedule
all early voting sites
as well as all election day vote centers
will serve as mail ballot drop-off
locations
please don't wait in line with those
people who are waiting to vote in person
go directly to the front there will be a
staffer manning the mail ballot drop-off
and you
simply have to drop off the ballot they
will confirm that it is sealed
and they'll confirm that you have signed
the envelope before dropping it in the
box
and that will be securely delivered back
to our office
also provided in your mail-in packet
will be a flyer
that gives you instructions on what to
do if you need to cure your ballot
if you have not signed your ballot or if
the signature does not match the
signature we have on file
these instructions will tell you what
you need to do in order to correct that
as provided by the secretary of state we
do have an electronic tool a mobile
application that you can also use
to quickly fill out the affidavit sign
it and take a picture of your id
and send that back electronically so
that we can cure your ballot
also included is the secrecy sleeve
and making use of all
of the paper that's on the secrecy
sleeve we've also provided the
instructions
that you need to follow in order to fill
out your ballot
on the outside of the secrecy sleeve is
your i voted sticker
please be sure and detach that sticker
before you send your ballot back to us
wear
prominently throughout the day or put it
wherever you want to display that you've
expressed your voice in the community
and voted in clark county
and finally you'll receive a mail ballot
this is a sample of the mail ballot that
all voters will be receiving
it's important to note for all voters
that there are two cards to every ballot
whether you're voting both cards you
still need to send
back both of these cards to the election
department
and i would emphasize to you that you do
not want to put
any identifying marks on either of these
ballots
so as i flip these you will see that
there is
voting contests on both sides of the
cards that we're providing
to mark selections on the ballot be sure
that you're making use
of a blue or black ink pen no felt tip
pens and no red ink
and simply mark the red oval to the
right of the candidate
of your choice on this sample ballot
i've already used my ink pen to mark the
candidate of my choice under president
you can clearly see that i filled in the
red oval which you need to do for all
contests
go through the entire ballot mark the
contests
in the same manner all the way through
if for some reason
you notice that you've made a decision
that you did not want to make
what i've also done here is correctly
make a change to my ballot
and you do that by simply drawing
through
the candidate that you did not want to
choose in this case
i did not want to vote no i wanted to
vote yes
so you draw a line through that
candidate and then mark the red oval to
the right
of the candidate that you want to choose
that is the correct way for you to make
corrections on your ballot
once you've voted the ballot you want to
go ahead and fold this
up removing the receipts that are on the
top
i'm going to switch samples here
to a ballot where i've already removed
the voting receipts that the voters
should keep
as a receipt that they've voted their
ballot
these stay with the voter however if you
forget to tear those off
it will not impact the processing of
your ballot
so now that i've removed those i'm ready
to fold those
fold the ballot according to the folds
that are already
printed on the ballot taking my privacy
sleeve
i'm simply going to insert it inside of
the privacy sleeve so that
when this is returned to us the privacy
of your ballot is protected
and then i insert it
in the return envelope be sure that you
seal your ballot
and again i emphasize you're going to
sign here at the bottom
on this red x with your signature so
that we can verify this signature with
the signatures on file
to verify your identity before we
process and count this ballot
once you've done that again you can
either make use of the postage paid
envelope
and drop this in the mail by november
3rd
in order for it to be returned to our
office if you decide to drop it off in
person
again all of the early voting and
election day sites will have mail ballot
drop-off locations for you to make use
of
one other item that i want to point out
on the back of this envelope
as a result of changes that were made in
ab4
in the special session anybody that you
trust
will reliably turn this ballot in for
you at the mail ballot drop-off location
or in a postal box
can turn this ballot in for you so this
box that we have here
is no longer necessary previously you
had to have a family member do that for
you
but in order to make it easier for folks
to get their ballots turned in
you no longer have to do it with a
family member anybody can turn this
ballot in for you
but you do not need to sign this area
so placing this into the mailbox or into
a mailbar drop-off box will start the
process for you
we'll get to work on processing it and
getting your ballot counted
again i'm joe gloria registrar of voters
in clark county
we hope that all voters in clark county
will take advantage
of either voting through the mail or
voting in person
during early voting or election day to
make their voice heard in the community
i would remind you that if you have any
questions related to your ballot you
should contact our office directly
at 702-455-vote
and we will be happy to help you with
any issues related to your ballot
thank you
and now i'll take some questions from
the general public
the first question is where will voters
be able to drop off their mail ballots
if they do not want to return them by
mail the easiest way to remember where
you can do a mail ballot drop-off is
that all early voting sites that are
scheduled
and all of the vote centers all 125 of
them will provide mail-ballot drop-off
locations
remember that i mentioned that you will
receive a mail ballot drop-off listing
as well
in with your mail ballot packet but it's
very easy to make that drop off again i
emphasize
do not wait in line with those people
who are waiting to vote in person
move to the front of that line and
there'll be a staffer inside that's
prepared to take your ballot
i received a postcard from the u s
postal service saying
i need to request my ballot but you said
we are automatically being sent one
what's going on that is very good
question
and unfortunately the us post office
decided to send a postcard
out to all 50 states and there are many
differences from state to state
you do not need to send in a mail ballot
request
for this election as a result of ab4 we
are sending mail ballots out
to all active registered voters so you
do not
need to follow the directions on that
postcard no mail ballot request is
necessary
what happens if a ballot is not signed
or the signature doesn't match
we're statutorily required now to send
information to the voter
indicating to them that they either did
not sign their ballot
or that the signature did not match the
signatures that we have on file
so in order to cure that ballot as i
mentioned in the video
the secretary of state has provided a
very useful tool so that you can do that
electronically through the mobile app
the mobile app instructions will be on
the flyer that we provide in the mail
and you go to that mobile app and you'll
sign the affidavit
and then using your smart device you
will take a picture of your nevada state
id
and send that to us to a secure site
where my staff can then download it
and cure your ballot and no it does not
need to be done in person
contact our office follow the
instructions
that we provide to you if we notify you
that
you have not signed or that the
signature does not match
also if you've provided an email or a
phone number in your voter registration
record
we will also try to contact you that way
as well
can a person deliver someone else's mail
ballot to the election department
the answer to that question is yes as a
result of ab4 again
uh used to be that a family member was
required to turn in the ballot however
to make it easier for folks to get that
ballot back to us if they
choose not to do it themselves or cannot
do it themselves they want to
make a wise decision in who they give
that ballot to but they can
have anyone return that ballot to us
either to put it in a mailbox or send it
to a mail ballot drop
off location
what steps have been taken to clean the
voter rolls of non-citizens
when you register to vote it's an
affidavit that you're signing
and the requirements are very clear
exactly
what you need to meet as as far as to be
eligible to vote
one of those things that you state on
that affidavit when you sign is that you
are a u s citizen
and so once they put that registration
form according to law we have to put it
into the registration the follow-up
question on that is has the county
reached out to federal departments to
cross-match citizen records with the
county voter roles
no such database exists if it did we
would certainly make use of it
but no such database that we can match
our records against either at the local
state or federal level
exists
how do we register to vote if we do not
have a nevada driver's license
leading up to the deadline for october
6th you can send in a mail ballot
or a mail voter registration form which
is available on our website
and also the secretary of state's
website or go to the many locations
where we have those forms
available which includes our office in
the city clerks and many post offices
and send that back to us by october
sixth
on that form you'll need to make sure
that you're putting the last four of
your social security
number and signing the affidavit getting
it back to us with the correct
residential address
as long as you do that by october 6 you
will not be required to have a nevada id
after that point your on your only
opportunity to register is online
and also through same-day registration
on election day or during early voting
and you will be required to have an id
for that registration
if i receive a mail ballot but i want to
vote in person can i
certainly we have made
good efforts to make sure that we
improve on our process from the primary
in the primary election we only had one
election day site and or
three election day sites and one early
voting site in comparison now in the
general we'll have 35 sites available
through the 14 day period and also on
election day there will be 125 vote
centers throughout the valley
a reminder to you we use vote centers in
clark county now
so it does not matter which location you
go to to vote in person your ballot will
be available
and if you do show up to vote in person
you can either bring your mail ballot
that you received in the mail with you
to surrender it at the polling place but
if you do not bring it with you
you'll simply have to sign an affidavit
that clearly states
that you do not intend to send that mail
ballot in
remember that it's against the law to
vote in two
twice in any election so either choose
to vote by mail
or vote in person
if i use the mail ballot to vote in this
election what do i need to make sure i
do
well following the guidelines that i put
in the video
what's most important that you do is
make sure that you
sign the return envelope on the outside
of that return envelope that's the
signature that we use
to make sure that your identity matches
what we have in the system
so that's the number one thing that you
need to make sure and do
then you need to make sure and get that
ballot turned into us before the
deadline
whether you're dropping it in the post
office mailbox
or delivering it to a mail ballot drop
off the deadline to have that dropped
off with the drop off or
in the post office postmarked is
november 3rd
we can accept any mail that comes in all
the way through
november 10th to make sure that we're
giving plenty of opportunity for that
postmark ballot to get in and if you
make it
to a mail ballot drop off as long as
it's deposited
by election day november 3rd we'll get
it processed and counted
are we able to track our mail ballot to
make sure it reached out reached you on
time
yes either using the secretary of
state's website or my website you can
log
into registered voter services at our
website
and check the status of your ballot it
takes time for us to process that ballot
and get it scanned into the system
to show what the status of that ballot
is
once we've received it so once you mail
it you need to give three or four days
at a minimum before you can check the
status
and see how we've received it and
whether it's being processed to be
counted
when will we know who won the election
unofficial results will be released on
election night
and that will represent the in-person
voting that took place during early
voting
and on election day minus the
provisional ballots
a mail ballots will continue to be
counted well after election day because
we have to process
all of the mail ballot drop-offs and
anything that comes through the mail
until after the election so the official
report will be
sent to the county commission for canvas
on november 16th
so that's when the official results will
be available for all to see
when will the mail ballots be counted
again as a result of ab4 they've
increased the amount of time that we
have here in clark county to count those
ballots
so 15 days prior to election day we will
begin to tabulate ballots
but not release counts on on results
we will have the number of people who
have voted
by mail however we won't release any
totals until
election night when we've received
confirmation from the secretary of
state's office that all 17 counties have
finished voting
after election night um we will continue
to release periodic results as far as
the status
on the counts related to what is being
counted on a daily basis that first
report will be available uh the thursday
after election day which would be
november 5th
how's the training and staffing coming
along for the election workers
we've received a tremendous response
from the general public
and we're very happy to report that it
looks like we'll be able to find enough
workers for both the early voting and
election day process
however we are definitely in need of
people who
can translate in spanish and filipino
which we're federally required to
support and
also we're looking to set up a special
hotline although we're not
mandated to do so we're going to
proactively work to try to provide
support
for those native languages in vietnamese
korean
and mandarin so if you have any of those
abilities to translate and you're
willing to work please contact our
office
and let us know that you're willing to
support and work the polls
will there be information about election
observers available
basically for any part of the process
anybody who wants to observe the
election either early voting or election
day
they simply need to check in with the
team leader at any of those sites
they'll have to sign some documentation
and of course follow the rules we'll
have a designated location
in all of our polling places where those
observers can watch
they cannot disrupt the polling place
while they're observing
and they cannot interact with voters
while they're in the process of signing
in
and casting their ballot if you need
additional information
feel free to call our office at
voters from 702-4555 19. we've had
tremendous support from the county
and our mac department that is providing
ppe to all departments
we are very happy to report there is no
shortage of supplies
and we are prepared to provide face
masks
face shields plenty of disinfectant
and plenty of signage to make sure that
we keep
people socially distanced as they're
waiting in line
and also to disinfect all hard surfaces
at all of the polling places
so peace feel comfortable that if you do
choose to vote in person
that they will be a safe polling place
however i will encourage you
if you're at all concerned about being
in large groups as a result of the
pandemic
this is the main reason why we've
provided you with a mail-in ballot take
advantage of that mail-in ballot and
send it back to us
when will i receive my mail ballot the
out-of-state are actually the overseas
ballots are going to be going out this
weekend
we meet met the deadline requirement and
out-of-state ballots will begin going
out the following week
all of the local ballots will begin
dropping into the mail on october 7th
so after that point i would
give it at least five or six days and if
you have not received your ballot and
you know you should have received one
you need to begin to contact our office
contact our office directly so that we
can make arrangements to either send you
a new ballot
or send one electronically to you so
that you can vote and get it back to us
to cast your ballot
i want to thank you for joining us
tonight at our town hall i hope that i
provided some valuable information
related to the election and giving you
the options that you can take advantage
of whether you're voting by mail or
whether you're voting in person during
early voting or on election day
as always information about the coming
election is also available on our
website which is www.clarkcountynv.gov
forward slash vote or you can always
call my office at 702-455-vote
please exercise your right to vote don't
lose your voice in the community come
out and vote
you